what is the next stop what is the next
category jerry you have the card as well
yes the next category is uh screen grab
of the year oh so i think we got a
little bit of crossover with this one uh
because i saw some of the nominations
but uh there are a lot of i guess this
is like out of context but just still
images yeah you know
it's kind of like the same energy uh but
you have even less context because
there's no clip to go along with yeah
sure all right let's see what the
nominations are oh sad gone again
wide-eyed gun angry aki
i love this one i love this one like you
need to see the full picture for you
yeah yeah yeah yeah
me in a banana clown
i don't really want to do that connor
takes his pants off that's that was
using a lot of me yeah yeah yeah and
then uh oh and i guess it's the sakura
miko us not it's not sacramento it's
just like it's just like
okay so this is actually really [ __ ]
hard because i don't know what my
favorite is i think my favorite maybe is
just trash taste in a nutshell yeah uh
just because like you you like you might
like
imagine it okay you're a few episodes
behind them on trash taste you know you
don't know you forget that we're doing
like a 24-hour livestream you see that
on your timeline and you're like what
the [ __ ] is going on with trash taste
what is actually a moment of like oh man
i haven't listened to the trash in so
long i wonder what they're doing here
i mean you see that
it's like pov you've missed one episode
of trash taste
oh my god wide-eyed god i don't know how
your eyes did that i love what i got i
don't even remember like what what did
you what was said that made you react
like time i don't even remember like
you're talking about you're drinking
budweiser
you're talking about like out of context
down here man i don't [ __ ] you though
if i remember correctly someone said
something you were like oh yeah i
assumed someone said something
get out of context wasn't it
was the incest thing i might have been
the incest thing why am i taking off my
pants i don't remember why i did that i
don't know either like your hand is like
on the belt yeah i already got it off i
also just love how an image from like
five years ago from a member that's not
even here is like nominated like why is
that it is a great image though yeah
yeah
trash tastes but i mean it's still it's
still on the meme verse i guess yeah
yeah what would you say is your favorite
trash station is another show it's
either that or angry aki as well yeah
which is just uh what was what was that
photo was the context what was the
context of that the context was so like
the full image is on the screen right
now but it's it's aki looking pissed off
because she was uh like
like sick like classic from when we went
on a bus tour yeah yeah and i'm talking
to my friend's girlfriend at the time
we're just having a conversation and
aki's just looking really pissed off
looking at me because she was really
sick
but out of context at least it just
looks like just pissed off me talking to
another people yeah yeah it's amazing
especially like that meme image of just
like the the girl looking pissed and
like the guy looking
back yeah yeah yeah honestly
yeah but yeah i i really love that image
overall and uh but i i gotta say trash
taste in a nutshell
like you could there's so much in this
detail there's so much detail in this
image if you just look at it that you
just like discover something new it's
like a piece of art the longer you look
at it the more impressive yeah
you look at that you're like why why is
god in a clown costume why is joey in a
banana suit why is connor playing a
monkey i didn't come donate
and then it's just like what what
current sigma comes
what is going on that's so
i love how like there's just so much
[ __ ] on the table
like it's so it's such a chaotic image
that i just i that's my favorite out of
context all right would you like to know
who was the winner yes yes yes sir the
winner of screen grab of the year goes
to
connor takes off his pass
too fair i think that one's used a lot
yeah yeah yeah that is useful
it's the combination of that and then me
and god yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah oh
no no no that is it that that is a combo
it's it's miss it's missing the second
half of the combo i just like how for
two years in a row it's me wearing the
same [ __ ] shirt and screen grab of
the year i'm wearing so
so so i'm like out of context clip of
the year then connor comes along with
like best screen grab of the year twice
in a row twice in a row
oh my gosh i do like this one i can't
remember why though i just thought it
was quite funny when people people
always reply to it with every tweet i do
they always reply with this
every single because because you could
fit it with so many different yeah yeah
it's like excitement but it's also like
horniness yeah it's like it's just like
the my body is ready
thank you thank you viewers yes
so what was the breakdown
uh connor takes off his pants one with
thirty two point four percent that was
quite fun
yeah trash taste in a nutshell came in
second with 20.4
nice nice yeah yeah yeah uh sat coming
in third with 19.3 of course of course
and then angry aki came in fourth with
12.8 percent of them nice all right nice
and fifth was banana clown joey i mean
that was just terrifying i i don't blame
you
yeah i thought i got i thought banana
joey would be the uh
banana clown joey would be the worst oh
sorry i'm reading it wrong why did i
gone did indeed come in
with seven point four seven point four
percent do you really have to like make
a deflection like that like
it's like debated actually you can't
fight it
here
[Music]
we got the most degenerative moment well
i think it's going to be one of you
right because i'm very wholesome i don't
know man you had some degenerate moments
yeah everyone has some degenerate
moments but uh let me just check that i
have yeah it's nice what are the
nominees what are the nominees
okay okay we got mainly talks about
sweat and spit this is from our cooking
special yeah uh play the clip have you
ever licked sweat
i mean not on purpose okay and how did
it taste i know what sweat is mainly i
know but like i know it's salty please
don't tell me you butcher it your
husband
not on purpose
a true melee moment
this is this is like a normal moment if
you hang out with melin enough she'll
just say some things and like i'm glad
that at least one of the moments has
finally been caught on camera so it's
moments like this where i'm like i'm so
glad i'm on meleen's good side yeah i
don't want to be like i don't know what
the [ __ ] she's gonna do like you can you
can literally see me processing like
where do i even start with this
you know when a friend says something
are you like yeah what
uh how like
i love i love this like a one second
paul
after she says it and me like mustering
up an answer being like uh
that's recording about it i was like
what was she what why don't you say that
and like the thing is right actually um
a bit of the the full conversation had
to be cut down yes right for like 40
minutes
so what you see what you saw in the
trash taste uh what in the trash day
special was a cut down version of uh of
the full conversation because she was
saying right this was cut out she was
saying that uh the the sweat of the chef
has like a slight like effect on the
taste of whatever we're cooking right
and uh and that's why that's why we were
talking about sweat being a seasoning
yeah because i got cuts out so i mean
out of context i'm just like i just i
just go to mainland it's like oh so you
want just only see one has to go like
like that yeah just like just wipe out
was talking about how foreign was like a
seasoning that like changed the flavor
of the food
she's so gross you didn't need to see
that part of the conversation obviously
like it was cut out for a reason god
bought an ass holder for his phone oh
yeah oh yeah yeah which is used over
there actually yeah i don't yeah i mean
we're still using it right now we can't
show it the patrons enjoyed that one the
patreon is very much enjoyed
but the figure
is just an ass
i'm gonna have to blow that
it's literally just an oh this is like
the this is like the way they get sucked
into a wall
stuck in the wall you only get half the
figure so it's just the ass
i feel this is like a one more combo of
me and god yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
two of these are wombo combo just me and
joey just being absolute degenerate i
just love how you described it you're
like it's just an ass
ass to ass
baby
and then next up we have groping
bumblebee oh my god oh
oh my god i thought we were still
showing the [ __ ] don't worry there's
plenty to spare what stuff oh my god oh
that's my hand
oh what's this oh that's my hand oh poor
bumblebee like full-on grabs the croc at
one
point yeah i think i think it's cut off
from this clip though i remember i
remember like cupping it and i was just
like i remember feeling like oh what's
that so smooth
what were you trying to get like a
massive [ __ ] it was like female 1
i don't know i just i just wanted to
feel the entire thing just so i could be
100 sure that's it that's it that's the
only reason and then finally we have uh
gant and connor reveal their lewd anime
figures play the club this is from one
of my favorite artists yom all right
okay i'll give it to you that's pretty
[ __ ] hot
let's go
is that removable i don't know well guys
it looks real
degenerates degenerate
i'm not the degenerate here i bought it
they are the ones who inspected it with
such
big vigorous energy i made a massive
mistake like giving it to us yeah
because i remember you just inspect like
i just had to like appreciate the detail
you know like on on like the cooch like
i'm just like god damn is that i was
like is that what that looked like
it was awesome i loved it i mean
as much as degenerate as that was it's
gotta be painful it's gonna be the one
right i'll be shocked i'll be shocked
yeah i'll be disappointed if it's not
the moment all right let's find out i
hope so so i can give a [ __ ] like
how does it feel to be like the most
degenerate person in trash taste melon
let's see who won yeah that's you oh
it's me oh i'm sorry i'm sorry he's like
yeah
guys guys guys anyone all right let's
find out and the winner of the most
degenerate moment is
maylin talks about switz bit and sweat
well deserved well done melin you have
somehow in like even though you're on
camera for like a tenth of the time it's
like not even a tenth like a hundredth
of the time so he's going on three
videos yeah you have somehow won the
most degenerate moment
in trash it wasn't even a competition he
wasn't even
what was it close actually was it close
no it wasn't
that's all we need to know that's all we
need to know can i just know the
percentage
what do you think it was 70 72.1 oh my
god
i knew it i know i didn't even need to
know the rest that's that's
melon everyone all right
milan's won her first trash chase awards
she's gonna come to the office later
today and we're gonna tell her that yeah
yeah yeah